[Musique]
et là messieurs le club de rome est un
groupe de réflexion qui réunit des
scientifiques des industriels des
fonctionnaires de 52 pays
en 1972 ils ont publié un rapport
intitulé de limit to growth les limites
de la croissance
à leur demande un groupe s'est réuni un
groupe de chercheurs du hem haïti et ils
ont mis le monde en équation
rien que ça et ils sont arrivés au
constat imparable que la grande
accélération que nous avons connue
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale allait
se terminer
et puisque l'ensemble des ressources de
la planète sont limitées et bien les
courbes un jour ou l'autre allait
s'inverser y compris celle de la
population mondiale
alors évidemment ou quand le monde
reçoit ce rapport c'est un peu l'état de
choc
les scientifiques et des économistes se
sont cabrés évidemment pour rejeter ces
théories disons le plutôt sombre
cependant les faits sont là consommer
des ressources de manière toujours plus
importante dans un monde où justement
elles sont limitées
c'est un mythe alors je me disais bien
que y avait quelque chose qui tournait
pas rond dans ce monde
j'avais un peu la sensation confuse de
pas être tout à fait à ma place
on est tous baigné dans une idéologie
dominante qui nous demande de travailler
plus pour gagner plus pour consommer
plus pour accumuler plus si possible
serait qu'on rêve de devenir
milliardaire avoir une rolex à 50 ans je
vous laisserai retrouver les auteurs de
ce magnifique formule alors que moi
quand j'étais gamin j'ai eu une
éducation ou bas on me disait non tu ne
peux pas mettre du yao du sucre dans ton
yaourt parce que c'est un désir est pas
un besoin
vous voyez un peu le genre d'éducation
ou en fait et bien il faut consommer que
ce que l'on a ou le plaisir est d'autant
plus intense qu'il est rare cela dit je
vous rassure j'ai manqué d'absolument
rien d'essentiel
et donc forcément et bien cette
éducation est venu heurter de plein
fouet sans que je comprenne trop
pourquoi ni comment
et bien cette idéologie dans laquelle
nous sommes baignés tous les jours
vingt ans après la publication du
rapport du club de rome un grand
philosophe a dit depardon george bush a
dit me we can way of life is not négoce
le bol le mode de vie américain n'est
pas négociable
il a dit ça à l'occasion du sommet de la
terre de rio alors que tous les pays de
la planète étaient réunis pour faire le
constat de dégradation de la biosphère
et donc il affirmait alors et bien que
en aucun cas on ne saurait remettre en
cause ce mode de vie du pays qu'il
représentait il marquait donc la
détermination des pays occidentaux dont
nous faisons partie et bien maintenir
coûte que coûte ce mode de vie comme
s'ils étaient généralisées généralisable
à tous et comme s'il était soutenable
sur le long terme alors
forcément et bien la conclusion c'est
rien n'est négociable
nous avons un mode de vie qui a été
construit pendant deux décennies grâce à
nos esclaves énergétiques alors
peut-être ce terme peut vous faire
réagir
l'esclave énergétiques alors laissez-moi
une minute pour illustrer mon propos un
litre d'essence coûte à peu près 1 euros
40 pour obtenir la même quantité
d'énergie il faudrait que nous pédalons
une centaine d'heures quatre jours
ininterrompus de pédalage pour avoir la
même quantité d'énergie qui a dans votre
litre d'essence
or chacun de nous ici dans cette salle
consomme chaque année toutes énergies
confondues l'équivalent de 4000 600
litres de pétrole
si on paye sa au prix de l'essence a
fait 6500 euros par personne si on le
paye au prix du cycliste ça fait 6 5
millions d'euros par personne
mille fois plus autant dire que
l'énergie qui a été mise à notre
disposition pendant les dernières
décennies et qui a permis de construire
cette société dans laquelle on évolue
était quasiment gratuite et ils sont là
nos esclaves énergétique
ils sont avec nous tous les jours il
nous accompagne à chaque instant à
chaque minute à chaque seconde
alors en parlant de slave énergétique et
bien dans mon ancienne carrière mon
ancien métier c'était techniciens aux
essais en vol chez airbus
j'ai participé au développement de cette
énorme avion
j'étais là au premier vol c'est moi qui
ai pris la photo c'est énorme avion qui
fait deux étages sur toute sa longueur
et emmène plus de 500 passagers 250
mille litres de carburant dans cl et
dans son ventre et c'était véritablement
passionnant vraiment et j'ai été très
fier de ce que je faisais et ma famille
aussi mes proches étaient fiers malgré
tout en 2003 je ressens comme un grand
vide comme une panne de sens
suit est bien un peu comme nous tous
dans une routine aussi quotidienne je
vais au boulot puis-je orange nous met
devant l'ordinateur ou la télé et puis
le samedi je vais faire les courses
et puis je suis tout le temps dans ma
voiture et c est un moment un vache
décide un soir d'aller à la réunion
mensuelle d'une ong environnementale et
ce soir là tout s'éclaire mes sentiments
deviennent des chiffres mais intuition
deviennent des images je prend alors la
mesure des délires sans limite du monde
moderne
pendant les quatre années qui vont
suivre où je vais m'investir dans des
associations diverses
je vais apprendre je vais comprendre
tout ce dont george bush a fait fi à
l'occasion du sommet de la terre
dérèglement climatique accès à l'eau
potable pic pétrolier accès à l'énergie
fossile avec tous les conflits que ça
génère consommation de masse
obsolescence programmée appropriation du
vivant par la droite dustrit avec les
ogm production de plus de produits
chimiques et toxiques avec toutes les
pollutions que ça peut générer dette
économique et écologique déforestation
désertification etc etc je prend alors
conscience que je peux plus passer
l'essentiel de mon temps l'essentiel de
ma vie à alimenter ce que lewis mumford
appelait la mégamachine c'est cette
organisation sociale dans laquelle
l'humain n'est plus que le rouage d'une
mes chaînes d'une mécanique complexe
dont la puissance est absolue je pouvais
plus passer l'essentiel de mon temps à
entretenir cette course infernale plutôt
que ce qui sauver ce qui pouvait l'être
encore
alors je décide de reprendre des études
et de devenir ingénieur en énergie
à l'époque je croyais encore qu'il
existait une énergie miracle une énergie
verte une énergie écologique
et puis que d'avoir mon diplôme me
permettrai de la promouvoir et puis
qu'on aurait un monde meilleur
malheureusement à la conclusion il se
trouve que l'énergie vraiment propre ça
n'existe pas au moins pour deux raisons
la première c'est que toutes les
énergies ont des avantages et des
inconvénients
la seule chose dont il faut qu'on
discute séquelles inconvénients nous
sommes prêts à accepter et la deuxième
c'est que consommer de l'énergie s'est
transformé notre environnement et que
donc plus aux consomme d'énergie et plus
on transforme notre environnement
depuis 1970 la moitié de la population
animale a disparu de la surface de la
surface de la terre depuis 1990 à peine
plus de 25 ans 1,3 million de kilomètres
carrés de forêts ont été rasés et ont
disparu de la surface de la terre
tel pétrole qui a permis tout ça c'est
le pétrole ce sont les énergies fossiles
ce sens d énergie extrêmement abondante
et gratuite
quasiment gratuite alors faisant ce
constat et bien je suis revenu en 2010
au pays de mes origines après avoir
passé quelques années à toulouse et je
suis revenu à châteauneuf-sur-loire avec
la conviction que nous allions vivre des
ruptures profondes et que ces ruptures
pourront être soit anticipée soit subie
alors je m'y colle tout seul ou avec ma
campagne son fils avec ma famille mes
amis mes voisins avec la ville de
châteauneuf et puis j'essaie au
quotidien est bien de réinventer une
manière de vivre sur cette planète qui
soit désirable et soutenable
et en fait il se trouve que c'est
probablement aussi excitant que
d'inventer comment on pourrait aller
vivre sur mars
c'est d'autant plus excitant que tout le
monde peut le faire alors il se trouve
qu'une partie de mon métier et bien
c'est justement de me projeter dans
l'avenir et d'imaginer à quoi pourrait
ressembler ce monde je fais de la
prospective
c'est à dire eh bien je me projette en
2030 2040 2050 et puis je me dis tiens à
quoi ça pourrait ressembler si justement
on pouvait mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de choses
alors j'ai fait un scénario vers des
territoires résilient domine 2030 la
scénario 100% renouvelable pour la
région centre val de loire à l'horizon
en ce moment je suis sur un scénario ile
de france sans voiture et sans pétrole à
l'horizon 2050 et du boulot donc mon
métier me permet comme ça et bien de
rêver demain
mais rêver c'est nécessaire certes mais
c'est pas suffisant il faut donc qu'on
se trouve une nouvelle voie de
prospérité qui ne soit pas une
augmentation de nos revenus une
augmentation de la surface de la maison
de la puissance de la voiture ou du
nombre de chaussures dans le dressing
il faut qu'on se trouve une nouvelle
ambition qui nous pousse tous les matins
quand on se lève qui nous donne envie
d'aller de l'avant
alors je vous fais une proposition ce
soir c'est celle et bien de la sobriété
heureuse et résiliente
la sobriété heureuse c'est un concept
qui a été
opposées par pierre rabhi est un agro
écologistes et philosophe le principe
c'est que tous les jours et bien on va
essayer de faire en sorte de diminuer
nos besoins en énergie en matériaux en
économie et en finances tout en
préservant voir en améliorant notre
niveau de bien-être
notre plaisir de vivre notre
convivialité la résilience c'est tout
autre chose c'est la capacité d'un
système donc ça peut être vous autant de
personnes ça peut être votre famille
votre quartier votre village la capacité
de ce système à subir un choc ou un
changement perturbant on pourrait
imaginer qu'on ait à en vivre certains
et à préserver les fonctions vitales
l'identité de ce système alors
concrètement comment ça se traduit pour
moi eh bien nous avons fait le choix
d'avoir une maison petite maison à
proximité du centre-ville pour pouvoir
tout faire à pied ou en vélo on a un
jardin de taille modeste mais qui nous
permet d'apprendre à faire un potager
pense que c'est que la culture d'avoir
quelques poules pour voir des jeux
éliminé quelques déchets on a aussi des
toilettes sèches qui nous permettent de
diminuer la consommation d'eau potable
et en scène fine excellent compost pour
le potager on a un poêle de masse aussi
qui nous permet de nous chauffer au bois
bûche de manière très performante et en
plus ça nous chauffe l'eau en hiver et
du coup l'été en hiver ou l'été pardon
et bien c'est notre chauffe eau solaire
qui prend le relais puis on est en train
d'installer aussi des panneaux
photovoltaïques pour faire l'électricité
etc
et à chaque fois qu'on passe une de ces
étapes
et bien c'est réellement un plaisir
intense de sentir qu'on gagne en
autonomie
on gagne aux connaissances de notre vie
de notre mode de vie et que en même
temps on diminue nos besoins et ont dix
minutes de fait notre impact sur la
biosphère
les transitions honneur comme on
pourrait nous appeler bien on pourrait
nous caractérisée comme des
catastrophistes optimiste c'est à dire
que nous sommes convaincus on va vivre
des choses pas forcément très facile
mais que nous avons encore aujourd'hui
la possibilité de nous y réunir de nous
organiser pour faire en sorte que les
choses se passent le mieux possible et
en toute convivialité encore une fois
alors à châteauneuf-sur-loire avec notre
groupe de transition qui s'inscrit dans
le mouvement international des villes en
transition et impulser par un professeur
de permaculture anglais qui s'appelle
rob hopkins et bien on a mis en place un
certain nombre de groupes donc on a un
groupe qui travaille sur l'alimentation
duquel a découlé et bien un groupe qui
travaille sur la production et la
conservation de semences
on a un jardin partagé dans un groupe
qui travaille sur la santé comment on
peut se soigner différemment et que par
des médicaments aujourd'hui sont faits à
partir de de pétrole notamment
on a un groupe de travail sur la
transition intérieur comment on peut se
changer soi même pour pouvoir ensuite
changer son mode de vie et essayer de
changer le monde
on est en train de lancer une monnaie
locale complémentaire pour transformer
aussi notre relation à l'économie et
puis enfin on a un très gros projet
depuis 2016 qui serait la première
maison de la transition c'est à dire
qu'il vient on s'installe dans une
brasserie plus grande brasserie de
châteauneuf plein centre ville au pied
de l'église est là dedans et bien on est
en train de faire des travaux pour faire
un gros projet associatif dans lequel il
va y avoir une épicerie bio zéro déchet
il va y avoir un café associatif et
culturel dans lequel les gens vont
pouvoir se retrouver de toutes
générations de toute culture pour faire
des jeux pour voir des expos des
concerts etc
des spectacles on va voir un espace de
coworking pour que les travailleurs
indépendants et et les travailleurs
puissent se retrouver dans ce lieu aussi
et lancer des projets ensemble
on va avoir une grande cuisine qui va
permettre de faire des ateliers de
cuisine aussi de deux produits
fabrication de produits cosmétiques
un atelier de réparation pour le vélo
pour les produits électroménagers etc
plutôt que de les jeter on va essayer
d'apprendre à les réparer enfin voilà
donc énormément de choses qui vont se
retrouver dans ce même lieu et qui vont
nous permettre justement est bien de
donner du relief à tout cela et de faire
en sorte et bien que collectivement on
avance vers et bien ce mode de vie plus
soutenable que il ne pourrait l'être
jusqu'à présent la planète est en train
de nous montrer ses limites
et ça c'est pas négociable alors on peut
quand même décidé de continuer d'en
profiter jusqu'au bout de ne rien
changer et puis advienne que pourra
on peut aussi décider de choisir plutôt
que subir
évolution du monde
la sobriété heureuse et la transition
vers la résilience locale
c'est une piste prometteuse que j'avais
envie de partager avec vous ce soir
cette transition que je vous ai raconté
en une quinzaine de minutes après quinze
ans de ma vie
le changement est long même lorsqu'on
est convaincu alors n'attendons plus
merci
[Applaudissements]